[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí América este es el
magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy la fiscal General del Perú
presentó una demanda contra el
presidente Pedro Castillo por supuestos
delitos relacionados con la corrupción
sin embargo la constitución del país
solo permite destituirlo por crímenes
contra la democracia o de traición a la
patria el mandatario se defiende y
asegura que se trata de un golpe de
estado lo es hablamos con un
constitucionalista en Lima y les
explicamos y visitamos Venezuela donde
según la Organización Mundial de la
Salud viven más de 4 millones de
personas en condición de discapacidad
Pero al menos el 40% de ellas son
excluidas del mundo laboral según
investigaciones de asociaciones
defensoras de sus derechos nuestra
corresponsal en Caracas habló con
algunos de ellos para conocer Cómo es
vivir con una discapacidad en un país en
crisis económica y social
y octubre es el mes de la
sensibilización sobre el cáncer de mama
el más común y la segunda causa de
muerte entre las mujeres de las Américas
vamos a ir a Brasil para conocer la
historia de un tatuador que dona su
talento para ayudar a mejorar la vida de
la sobrevivientes
Y empezamos hablando de Perú y su
perpetua crisis política esta semana la
fiscal general Patricia Benavides
presentó una denuncia constitucional en
contra del presidente Pedro castillo
acusándolo de supuestamente dirigir una
organización criminal así como de
tráfico de influencias es la primera vez
en la historia del Perú en la que se
utiliza este mecanismo el mandatario
defendió su inocencia y aseguró que se
trata de una nueva modalidad de golpe de
estado la decisión recae ahora en el
congreso que tiene 10 días para decidir
gran parte casi desde el inicio de su
mandato el presidente Pedro Castillo ha
estado en una pugna de poder con el
congreso que ha invocado en dos
ocasiones una moción de vacancia en su
contra con el fin de destituirlo sin
lograrlo trabaje los proyectos de ley
para hacerlo había hecho uso del
mecanismo que permite removerlo del
poder en caso de incapacidad moral un
término ambiguo que ha sido usado en el
pasado como mecanismo de control
político pero que fue adherido a la
Constitución originalmente con el fin de
poder destituir a un mandatario muerto o
enfermo la investigación es muy sólida
el ex secretario general del Palacio de
Gobierno se ha cedido a la colaboración
eficaz y ha declarado esos tacos de
corrupción
funcionarios de muy allegados al
presidente de la república han declarado
en esto O sea no es una persecución
política es una investigación muy muy
seria Cuántos hospitales carreteras
comisarías puentes obras públicas en
general se dejan de hacer el dinero va
destinado a la corrupción es algo
insostenible en paralelo una fiscalía ha
iniciado seis investigaciones en contra
del Castillo sin que ninguna pueda
rendir frutos debido a que el presidente
de Perú tiene inmunidad para ser
procesado por el poder judicial A menos
que según la Constitución peruana Cometa
algunos de estos cuatro delitos
traicionan la patria cerrar el congreso
sin estar autorizado no convocará
elecciones impedir la reunión de
organismos electorales la demanda
interpuesta por la fiscal Patricia
Benavides Por delitos de corrupción
tráfico de influencias y corrupción no
está dentro de estas causales son
artículos que hoy en El Siglo 21 son
anacrónicos y obsoletos pero están allí
qué solución hacer Bueno la fiscal de la
nación propone al parlamento que
interpretando el los tratados
internacionales como la convención de
las Naciones Unidas para lucha contra la
corrupción pueda
levantarse ese obstáculo
salía lo que ha hecho es presentar
el informe la investigación al congreso
de la república Y decirle usen ustedes
la denuncia constitucional
o usen la que consideren a bien pero son
ustedes congreso de la República como
poder legislativo los responsables
de poner una solución a este problema a
14 meses de su llegada al poder Castillo
ha pasado la mayor parte de su mandato
cambiando su gabinete y Sobreviviendo a
los intentos del Congreso por
destituirlo y no ha tenido margen de
maniobra para atender los verdaderos
problemas que aquejan a la población
como la inseguridad alimentaria que
según la FAO es la mayor de Suramérica o
poder legislativo con los 130
congresistas el poder ejecutivo con el
presidente el 19 ministro y el poder
judicial no es uno que tenga más poder
que otro hay un peso Si contrapesos
pero el problema no es las instituciones
El problema es que los gobernantes en el
Perú de los últimos años han caído en
serios casos de corrupción la dinámica
hace que el poder legislativo tenga un
84% de desaprobación y Castillo un 65%.
según el más reciente sondeo del
instituto de estudios peruano el 60% de
los ciudadanos quiere elecciones
anticipadas tanto para renovar el poder
legislativo como El Ejecutivo
vamos a revisar brevemente las noticias
de Estados Unidos de esta semana el
comité del senado que Investiga el
asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 por parte de Seguidores de Donald
Trump cuando los legisladores
certificaban los resultados de las
elecciones en las que fue electo Joe
biden aprobó de manera
unánimecitara el expresidente a declarar
al respecto además reveló imágenes
inéditas de ese día en el que se vea las
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi llorando y
pidiendo ayuda Trump No aclaró si
asistirá o no pero envió una carta al
panel asegurando que nuevamente sin
pruebas hubo fraude electoral en esos
comicios de 2020
el Jurado del caso contra Nicolás Cruz
el joven que asesinó a 17 personas en
una escuela secundaria de parkland en
Florida en 2018
recomendó sentenciar a cadena perpetua
al atacante en vez de pena de muerte en
contra del joven de 24 años algunos
padres se mostraron decepcionados Pero
el hecho de que su madre hubiera
consumido alcohol durante el embarazo
fue uno de los atenuantes de la decisión
la condena será dictada en noviembre
Cruz utilizó un rifle que compró
legalmente y hablamos de otro tiroteo el
de Sandy Hook en Connecticut en 2012
porque esta semana el locutor Alex Jones
fue condenado a pagar 965 millones de
dólares a las familias de las víctimas
por haber dicho que el hecho se trató de
una farsa para incentivar según él los
controles de armas en la Unión Americana
este es uno de los tiroteos más
mamíferos de la historia del país dejó
28 víctimas mortales y el autor Adam
lanza lo perpetró con un rifle que
adquirió legalmente
vamos a hablar ahora de Venezuela el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro defendió su
gestión para garantizar los derechos de
las personas en condición de
discapacidad en el país sin embargo
organizaciones no gubernamentales Y la
población misma lo contradicen y
denuncian que la protección de sus
derechos se ha quedado solo en el papel
nuestra corresponsal en Caracas Daniela
Zambrano preparó el siguiente informe al
respecto
Carlos Fuentes ha vivido la mayor parte
de su vida en silla de ruedas tras un
accidente que lo dejó cuadripléjico se
traslada en transporte público pero las
precarias condiciones del servicio y la
falta de infraestructura para personas
con discapacidad complican aún más su
movilización no hay escaleras eléctricas
operativas este tengo que pedir ayuda a
algunos buenos samaritanos que pasen
para que me ayuden a bajar la escalera y
si por una mala suerte se llegan a caer
imagínense rodar por todas esas
escaleras en esta condición es terrible
desde 2007 en Venezuela está vigente la
ley para personas con discapacidad que
abarca derechos y garantías en materia
de Educación trabajo accesibilidad y
Transporte pero en la práctica no se
cumple Los afectados Como yisandra quien
perdió la mayor parte de su movilidad en
un accidente de tránsito denuncia que en
el país las personas con discapacidad no
tienen acceso al mercado laboral formal
sino trabajo independiente no tengo
este
posibilidad de que alguien me me
contrate pues una silla de ruedas por su
alto costo también resulta inaccesible
para la mayoría hay quienes como
yisandra han logrado adquirir las
gracias a fundaciones privadas que
reciben dinero desde el exterior y hemos
entregado 10.000 y pico de sillas y
sacando la cuenta el otro día nos daba
una silla por día que suena tonto pero
no no es no es bien complicado el pasado
mes de julio el parlamento venezolano
aprobó en primera discusión un proyecto
de ley para garantizar la inclusión
laboral y adecuación de los espacios de
trabajo para personas con discapacidad
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
estima que en Venezuela y cerca de 4
millones y medio de personas con algún
tipo de discapacidad sin embargo el
último censo oficial hecho en el país
fue en el 2011 la falta de estadísticas
dificulta la atención de esta población
octubre es el mes de la concientización
de la lucha contra el cáncer de mama y
vamos a Brasil donde cada año se
detectan 66 mil casos nuevos de esta
enfermedad nuestra corresponsal en Río
de Janeiro nos lleva a conocer a Beto él
es un tatuador que usa su arte para
reconstruir de forma gratuita los
pezones de las mujeres que pasaron por
una mastectomía y una posterior
reconstrucción mamaria veamos el informe
en abril de 2020 el mundo de Karla se
vino abajo en plena pandemia descubrió
durante un examen de rutina que tenía un
cáncer maligno en el pezón
ya que nos fue ahí el diagnóstico fue
complicado porque
porque me pidió en un momento de
sufrimiento
un mes Antes había perdido a mi madre
los médicos se retiraron la areola de su
seno además Carla Tuvo que pasar por un
ciclo de quimioterapia
al final esta mujer consiguió vencer la
enfermedad a sus 41 años solo desea
volver a la normalidad
me siento un poco yo me siento un poco
mutilada no tengo mucho valor de mirarme
en el espejo porque sé que está faltando
una parte de mí misma
Hoy es el día en que Carla va a
recuperar su autoestima gracias al
trabajo solidario de un tatuador
hace 11 años Beto realiza tatuajes
gratuitos a mujeres que perdieron sus
mamás
ya te hicieron un injerto alguna vez
Beto examina los pechos de Carla para
poder copiar exactamente su pezón
es un procedimiento rápido pero muy
preciso en poco más de media hora Beto
tatúa la areola completa el resultado es
espectacular
yo no veía Carla veía otra persona Ahora
estoy viendo a la Carla de verdad
decenas de mujeres han vuelto a sonreír
gracias a la generosidad de este
profesional que no cobra por este
servicio
otros tatuadores en el mundo podrían ver
eso sensibilizarse y ayudar otros
tatuadores podrían unirse a hacer la
misma cosa porque no cuesta nada es un
trabajo de 40 minutos que va a dar
felicidad a una mujer por el resto de su
vida
Beto sigue cuidando de esas mujeres
incluso después del tatuaje alguna como
Marcia vuelve a por otro un lazo rosa
que identifica a las pacientes
oncológicas
equilibrio el seno provoca equilibrio no
es solo por la lactancia representa
mucho para una mujer cuando me hice el
tatuaje del pezón lloré pero de alegría
porque está completa de nuevo entre
comillas
este lazo puede ser mucha diferencia en
caso de emergencia porque una paciente
sin ganglios linfáticos no puede recibir
pinchazos en el brazo
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Luis Fernando Montes
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web France 24.com y
Para más información de nuestro
continente Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]